why do you think there are so few
journalists like you
you you're basically the embodiment at
least in the space you operate of what
great journalism should be
why do you think there's very few like
you
that's such an enormous compliment and
probably overstatement but
um
I first want to pay respect there are a
lot of great journalists and a lot of
them
are like I don't want to just kind of
take it and go yeah you know it's just
me there's so many great journalists
Matt Levine Kelsey Piper
um you know you've got Anonymous
journalists like Dirty Bubble you've got
citizen journalist like Tiffany Fong but
yeah but
I think
if you're going to be in the space in
the long term you do need to accept
certain risks and I think in the long
term it's like
I don't know how easy it is to play that
game for a long period of time
because you make
to do great journalism you don't get
paid a lot compared to what you could
get paid if you did press pieces or
anything like that
you take a lot of risks legally you take
physical risks you take
it's just like if you care about money
it's not the profession
and I feel like
a lot of people when they get notoriety
they move to like well I can just
maximize the money security side of
things and I think it takes out a lot of
would-be great journalists
and also so first of all comfort of a
physical and mental well-being yes and
also being invited to parties with
powerful people uh you um
you make enemies rich and Powerful
enemies doing this
yes
but that's why it makes it
that's why it's admirable I mean you
know uh it's it's an interesting case
study that you've been doing it as long
as you have
and I hope you keep doing it but it's
just interesting that it's rare
I'll say
I want to make a call like I think
societies can create
better journalists and worse journalists
insofar as they support the journalists
who are doing great work and I want to
call out Edward Snowden specifically
because what we have done to him is such
a travesty and the only lesson you can
learn if you're a logical human being is
that you should never whistleblow on the
United States Government after looking
at what they did to Snowden so
as a society
we can put pressure on lawmakers to make
it easier for people to do the great
work
by not punishing the people who do great
work if that makes sense and de-risking
it for them because we shouldn't expect
journalists to be martyrs to do great
work right to do important work and part
of that comes from protecting
whistleblowers there's like very common
sense things I love like it's great to
heroicize you know people like Edward
Stone and stuff like that but we
shouldn't expect them to be heroes to do
that work